on the last film i was talking about
uh the canon shanagi
i'd like to now talk about the
the theory of what you should be
thinking about in aikido
when i see a lot of stars
i actually wonder where they get their
information from
even the very very top teachers out
there
masters some of them are
known as kindergarten
was a technique well it is a technique
that everybody loves
and uh it's a lot of fun throwing uki
especially on them when when we'll be
younger you know
couldn't do enough kind of issues on
people
anyhow doesn't matter if it's multiple
attack
or uh an individual attack
or even training on the titanic
i believe that you should always think
that they're coming to you
even if you know you know i'm here and
i see somebody coming to attack me if
they've decided to attack me
and it's a multiple attack i would go to
them
so that there's some rhythm this
movement
if i'm just standing here waiting for
them to hit me
and i've then got to move at the last
second
i may not be quick enough if i
if i sort of go to meet them and step
offline
just as we're about to come together and
come here
it makes sense to me so
if we can just agree for a moment that
they're they the attacker would be
coming to me or your partner on the
tatami
you know you offer a hand you're off
work
shoulder whatever you offer your body
whatever you offer
there comes you so why would you then
enter if it's not from a rumor
a remy is an entrance to the rear
so it means that you're actually going
to meet them past them and beyond them
there's not many iremies done in aikido
forget the narco part the throwing part
there's not many
entrances because if you
enter incorrectly you perhaps become the
attacker
if you enter to blend by going to the
side
it makes more sense i'd like to just
look at the kadagash on the film
previously there was
a show about the hand and the feet
the hand and the feet the hand the feet
the body
and the feet both feet the body the turn
the sheer legging
you'll notice that my hands are
with me all the time over the head and
come
down from the head
many people that do shin aggies you'll
see them come here
and keep it not over the head but around
the head
and it will pass behind their head and
then
about here at this point
they throw the person down with their
arms
this was one of the points that i was
talking about earlier
about when i see weapons i see cats done
like this
but there's a lot of this done in what
we call cash in my bokken
scentsy cheeba was a very very powerful
master
and you wouldn't want to mess with him
but and
if i put my body moving
i i you can create tremendous power
and it is body movement but there's a
lot
done with just the simplicity of the
wrists
so it's a little bit like the wrists
start to move
and then the body engages
let's look at go back to the code guys i
offer
i have me again just because it's easy
they come to grab this
if i enter like that and then try and
take it away
i've gone towards them when really i
wanted
to go this way because this is the way
they're coming
so i should turn it on the spot offer it
turn it on the spot there's the movement
of the ken
offer turn it on the spot
take hold of the wrist and with the
thumb
in the hand
if you turn on the ball of the foot
or the feet first one
and the other this is where it would go
without going back into them
so don't go back into them you'll see a
lot of youtube
where they they throw it back into them
the only time you'll do
this is if they have a knife and you're
trying to
put the knife into their face so that
you have something against them
that they're trying to use on you
apart from that the psychology taught me
the the uh kind of guy she taught me was
take it out of the way and it's a little
lead forward
you turn stepping out
sweeping with this foot sweeping with
this foot
and there coat guys
is a small wrist twist don't take my
word for it look in the books
and you'll see that's what it says a
small wrist twist
it's not a small wrist twist and an
elbow collapsing a small wrist twist and
an elbow collapsing
it's a small wrist twist the arm stays
like this
okay goes up and over
their own wrist like a katherine well
this is now if you're at home and you
don't have a partner or you can't train
at the moment because a lockdown
you can do these techniques you can
stand there
do your do you like it
how does it feel is your
first foot out of sync are you shifting
your body weight
across the line of attack
this is all wrong you know is your
timing out
can you make it smooth
can you learn to use mass
shear and aggie i was talking about
earlier is mass
here your mass builds your mass builds
your mass builds
you become one with your attacker
so i'd like you to just consider what
i've said
uh on this film and if somebody's coming
towards you
like i'm coming towards the camera why
would
i go towards
them as well
i should be offering
not going any deeper towards them
and if i want to go this way then we are
both in harmony going the same way
and then keeping in keeping in the
harmonious way of moving forwards
together
this is what i believe is aikido
this is harmony with both
two people become one eye open
they come so that i'm out of their line
of attack
and i throw them without going back over
that line
i hope you've found this of interest and
i'll try and explain how i see more
techniques
and the weapons as we go a lot of
uh people i've met who do one more
echidna
they say that hasso guys with the joe
is like irimanagi and it sort of is
but the part that um i
like looking at is the way the
remy works and the way we pass
cytosensor used to say it's like two
trains on the same track
and as they come at the last minute they
pluck they pass each other
because somebody's um
moved the links on the tracks so that
they're on the same one
and they move the links and they buy
parts like this
this was his way of explaining it two
trains on the same track
but the points were moved and this is at
the last minute you blend
on the same track the last minute you
blend
this is irumi okay i hope you enjoyed it
thank you for your time